in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions Pete
and Terry are with us hey guys there
were yeah hey day we're good how are you
better than I deserve where you guys
from Georgia
what part Conyers okay very cool good to
have you guys and you're here to do your
debt-free scream absolutely how much of
you paid off a hundred thousand way to
go and how long did that take seven
years and two months seven years and two
months and your range of income during
those years fifty-eight thousand
president presently eighty nine thousand
Wow nice increases what do you guys do
for a living I'm a surgical tech alright
and I was retired and I couldn't hang it
anymore so I'm grabbing a special needs
school best there you go that's fun
good for you so seven years and two
months I'm guessing this last hundred
thousand might be your house it was very
cool you guys are heroes way to go proud
of you so tell me your story well how
did you get started seven years and two
months ago on this paying off the house
idea at the end of 2008 I started
listening to you and I go over to Pete I
go well Dave said and Dave did this and
dave says to do this and he went why
would I want a piece I made to get me
out of it
I just made sure that the TV was on when
you were on and the radio was always
said in both cars to where you had to
listen to you so there you go fitting
the kool-aid and then it took it took
root it did okay and then it was Pete's
idea yes that's a smart wife I'll tell
you I don't know anybody that's ever
happened to before named Dave right but
oh my gosh way to go you guys way to go
so seven years and two months ago you
started doing this and paying off the
house was part of the program running
yes so tell me what happened after you
got him listening to Dave then um he got
on board and
minute we started going through FPU I
sunned this up for coordinating FB you
didn't even get finished before I said
we're gonna start helping other people
Wow so we've done 15 so far 15 classes
you guys are Rockstar coordinators wow
we are so excited we just we drank the
kool-aid we are there we want everybody
else to be there oh my gosh and now you
get to tell all those classes that you
paid off your house no they get to hear
it all I guess when we do our next class
and living the dream we are we are
that's very cool
we did have some issues though along the
way one one I had to have three major
surgeries during this time so it's
slowed down our progress um took away
quite a bit of my income and so that's
why it seemed to take so long and I'm a
a personality so the minute you know I
see something I want it done tomorrow I
don't want to wait so I got a little
discouraged but what helped me get
through it was the FPU classes hearing
people go through small victories made
me feel good and it lit my fire and kept
me going to where I didn't get
discouraged very cool good for you guys
well there's something about teaching a
class that makes you learn it that's
that'll keep you honest he'll do that
ultimate accountability it really is you
know it's kinda like me sitting in this
seat I've got like two and a half
million accountability partners every 20
minutes yeah yeah if I go borrow money
to be on the front page of The National
Enquirer so of course nothing on that's
true anyway but anyway hey you guys
congratulations so what do you tell your
classes the secret to getting out of
debt is well we need to be on the same
page without that you can't do anything
you're just beating your head on the
wall as far as I'm concerned that was my
wallet one step at a time
she wanted to go from one to four and
back to three and five and seven she
wanted to make up her own bro that's why
that's why they called it one it's meant
to
for you I like it though she covered my
all up except what we working on one
would get it then she'd move the paper
down one more I'll show the next one so
you can't can't even look at it that's
good
no focused that's smart focus and
working together those are huge things
yes it's amazing what you can accomplish
if you do that and now you what's the
home worth probably probably about 150
okay yeah paid for yes yes it is you
know your house is paid for that's
pretty cool we're still making the
mortgage payments to yourself yeah yeah
that'll make you wealthy roughly figure
out real quick how much money you've
been given those goobers yeah oh well
congratulations you too I'm very proud
of you and thank you so much for leading
so many Financial Peace University
classes you've changed a lot of lives
well thank you so much for being who you
are and what you've come up with and
making us able to do that exactly we
appreciate it and honor to meet you guys
all right Pete and Terry Conyers Georgia
$100,000 paid off seven years in two
months making fifty eight to eighty nine
thousand count it down let's hear a debt
free scream three two one thank you
Jesus
way to go you two way to go very very
well done man that's how it works
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show and so you have to break the
cycle you have to flip this thing on its
head and make it behave you've got to
get so fired up and wired up that you're
broke friends think you've lost your
mind